Santander Colombia rich with wildlife
such as the majestic and delicious
big-ass out I am so sorry for that
terrible impression let's go eat some
ants roll the title
[Music]
these are all migas colonists otherwise
known as big-ass ants no really that's
the name here in Santa kill people love
to snack on the little critters but to
get them fresh they have to move quick
as they only above ground for one day a
year
yes that's 24 hours only to get your
aunt's fresh this is Adrian he's an
expert when it comes to hunting them
when I start riding the Las fermitas a
severe trauma is the muchos anos second
sermon muchas cosas de los origin is
cumulative per se own and make la la
manera I collect Arles la manera
oppressor tambien KD bus a little
abanazar little azure migas my muchas
personas que no boost and else our del R
Omega is in case our exact Oahu Karachi
you know no lotto Lyra pero en général
de Santander Janos somos los que nos
hemos con el gusto nos angry algo como
una to doll chimera rose la Papa
tortillas is algo importante para
nuestra cultura now a jump is a coma
Noonan Opa Opa right Stan their
resources si tengo una lira
yeah koala lira yeah I'm not that with
the flamin hot cheetos
anyway if you're looking for something a
little more restaurant friendly what
would you suggest elsa aqui estamos una
salsa or Meadows muy deliciosa
para lo mo chedda keaton la sala lloyd
Pequannock Pataca SE SE ponen hunt a ho
know the alamo colo color no se puede
her sin sin estaba jugando no
yeste que el punto es que cuando está
toast i go buenas Omega se sell Akua
East LHIN soos ingredientes Celeron
sabor Alhassan okay Anita a nice person
eaten Clarita el sabor muy rico
delicioso porque es a boat on a grass
eater una cita co y es muy rico
little solace it is very fusion and now
the most important part with taste
pretty good
tastes like chicken that big-ass ants of
Colombia utterly delicious
hi I'm Austin a nun producer from the
try it like it season click the link
below to see other episodes